one reporter who made it to the Florida
Keys compares the damage to a war zone
most of the low-lying islands are
devastated and have no running water or
communications at this time almost
53,000 utility customers and the keys
are without power right now route 1
that's the only Road in and out was
closed for inspection following the
storm now the first people are being
allowed back in mark Strassmann is near
route 1 in Florida City that's a gateway
to the keys mark good morning
good morning there are so many evacuees
who are highly anxious for the chance to
see what's left of their homes and they
are about to get that chance I want to
show you something it is a live look at
a long line of cars these are storm
evacuate seized evacuate approaching a
police checkpoint they're going home
because the band that kept them out of
the Upper Keys was just lifted at 7:00
a.m. local time and whatever these folks
find at home is just the first step of a
marathon recovery process this is the
Florida Keys in the wake of Hurricane
Emma a 115 miles stretch of Paradise now
overwhelmed with debris and destruction
totally demolished in places like
marathon people's homes were obliterated
oh my gosh by 130 mile per hour winds
and nearly 15 feet of storm surge live
on ocean you got there
take the chances about 30 miles away in
Key West
irma leveled homes and businesses
sections of the Overseas Highway the
only route in and out of the keys are
inaccessible crews are racing to clear
the road for first responders trying to
reach those who need help
County officials say the 42 bridges that
span the keys need to be inspected
before all the keys can be reopened
about half those bridges were reported
safe by Monday evening they continue to
evaluate the infrastructure the roadways
the health hazards that they find prior
to allowing the residence to come in but
frustrated Floridians are running out of
patience I just want to get home I have
water I have food I have dogs and I
can't get to miss should have been
thought out you look again at the police
checkpoint the live a queue is heading
into the Upper Keys they show a yellow
sticker or an ID that proves their
residents they were allowed to return
home there are three u.s. Navy ships
positioned off the east coast of Florida
including an aircraft carrier to help
with the recovery effort and this is
such a humanitarian crisis and much of
the keys that the Department of Defense
is considering whether they have to
evacuate 10,000 people who run out the
storm because conditions are just so bad
their normal mark incredible reporting
thank you so much